is Ariel black yeah yes era hawani
converted it's fully black no no like
Ariel like uh the new Little Mermaid
you know uh Chloe and Haley those girl
the sisters the singers and [ __ ] like
that this is how they silence black
women dude
this is what they do
how they silence black women they're
like how can we give them a role we
don't have to hear their [ __ ] voices
oh there you go there it is absolutely
you gotta know a little bit let's do a
movie where 70 of it she cannot speak oh
my God just walking around being black
how do you feel about it well she's
actually swimming so it's pretty
Progressive this is true this is
true let's see it
[Music]
Doug the videos you were telling me
about do you have any of those
[Music]
that's good come on let's build it
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
how old is she before we say anything
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
I mean very pretty yeah
22. very pretty yeah she's very pretty
girl an amazing voice I mean I'm a fan
bro yeah I like this yeah I'm all in
yeah I thought it was weird to have
Little Mermaid live action to me it just
worked better as a cartoon but I think
if you cast a Little Mermaid it has to
be her yeah she's got like the eyes like
the big eyes and all that it just she
actually even though she's black looks
more like Ariel than most actresses I
can think of and I think she looks like
a fish no I said big eyes I didn't say
she has like she does have big old eyes
a little mermaid's not a fish dude she's
a mermaid yeah so the top half is all
human yeah it's all fish
[Laughter]
yo here's hypothetical if you're stuck
on an island okay you you it's only you
and a mermaid yeah yeah would you rather
be a mermaid like this top half human
bottom half fish you can't have sex with
a fish [ __ ] yeah or it's flipped top
half fish bottom half human
Mark that was worse than mine is there a
rewind button yeah that was worse than
mine yeah
bro yeah are you kidding me I just sit
on the Dock of the Bay Sitting on the
Dock of the Bay right yeah and with my
feet in the water and then I just have
her come up and then just blow it out
every single time yeah you act like
there's only one way to have sex but
then you wouldn't be able to smash
there's no there's no legs I'm just
smashing throat yeah but how long are
you gonna do that for you're on an
island for a year oh blow jobs get
boring after all yeah
what are you talking about your version
until you're 29 years old
son you marry this girl this is the only
married woman would ever give you head
yeah yeah they're not [ __ ] great
start chumming the water so she knows
when it's time
all right guys we're gonna take a break
from this exclusive patreon clip because
I gotta tell y'all about hard dicks and
who's giving them to you that's right
fellas Bluetooth the best in the
business okay same active ingredients
inside Viagra Cialis but no one wants
that old [ __ ] we want the new we want
the chew and we want the one that's
gonna blow backs out all fall okay and
you want to know what you're going to
get it for free that's right free the
first month all you gotta do is pay five
dollars shipping just go to
bluetooth.com okay use the promo code
flagrant and you get that first month
free pay that five dollar shipping and
blow backs out because that's what
you're trying to do now let's get back
to this exclusive patreon clip join the
[ __ ] Army at patreon.com flagrant and
we're back I don't know where we uh
stopped but uh we're back we're still
talking about um
uh The Little Mermaid Little Mermaid I
think they're calling it
[Laughter]
so right now Dove has told us there's
some there's some very touching moments
that were captured which are young black
girls that are seeing a black mermaid a
black Little Mermaid for the first time
and we're gonna watch it
[Music]
she said
let's take it a bigger screen just kind
of move up a little bit
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
what about her skin
oh holy [ __ ] dude I'm gonna cry
oh
what baby
yeah she's brown like you
yay
oh that was that was really beautiful
yeah I'm about to cry amazing and that's
why you do it but they're all gonna
bootleg it that's the thing that's gonna
be [ __ ] up about it right how you got
to talk to the community
[Laughter]
do you remember that moment for you what
[Laughter]
I was gonna say Eminem
after Jack Harlow bro that's what I'm
saying all this time you should feel
that way about Eminem you didn't cry
when you saw me no I made fun of him and
Jameel was the one that was like nah
he's actually got barged I clowned I was
like oh who's this white guy trying to
rap that was you projecting bro of
course yes it was but really in your
core though you saw this and you were
like
looks like me no but there had already
been Eminem when you saw Jack Harlow
yeah no but I didn't have him he didn't
have my heart that wasn't him there's
already been princess of the Frog by the
time there's been Ariel okay but this is
my Jack heart what did you what what did
you first real talk it was Aladdin
Aladdin real first one Aladdin I was
like I have to support this movie I
Didn't I you know I knew it was in India
but I was like it's never going to be
India so let's just support this can I
be honest with you I thought Aladdin was
white yeah like I was like yeah he's a
white guy I look crazy but I I thought
he was white was white
yeah because you probably grew up in the
world was only black people and white
people you that makes less sense what oh
you know why he thought he thought you
reflected you and your Indian you know I
mean in your soul yeah I know I'm also
Indian but I thought he was a white guy
I just thought he was white they were
cartoons their voices were white guys
yeah they sounded look at that guys the
voice was a white guy the voice was the
white guy from Full House it's like me
in the summer dude like that
guy that guy's me in this that guy's
darker than Bala bro you're at a
stand-up show that guy's in the front
row wearing that and you look at me go
yeah what's up [ __ ] six years old
okay I don't know like white people
dress weird yeah the clothes looked
Indian enough like Jasmine in particular
I didn't know what Indian was
oh [ __ ] this is as close as it's ever
gonna get no I understand why you fell
out that way I'm just saying for
whatever reason why I did it on purpose
what they probably gave him a white
voice on purpose they made him look away
where I was like oh
do you think that that's what Hollywood
did but then I think that that was a
strategic decision to make more money
hey if you make him sound like a white
guy okay so why would you bring that up
people dabbling all over the [ __ ]
place you know what I'm saying that's
what I'm saying it doesn't sound white
though we're not talking about what he
sounds we're talking about how he looks
when I looked at his [ __ ] skin and
face okay there's no way that's a white
male to me
[Music]
[Music]
she's the queen she Grooms it you know
what I mean oh God bless her yeah anyway
the point is this was a white movie
I don't know the first black cartoon I
saw
first move on was the first minority
cartoon Little Bill I saw a little Bill
what was a little Bill that was on uh
Nick what was it Nickelodeon oh yeah
Nick Jr is Bill Cosby's cartoon yeah
Little Bill no it was Bill Cosby right
yeah yeah little Billy's like a little
like card Fat Albert the 70s yeah and
then the proud Scooby-Doo movies with
the Harlem Globetrotters what about that
there was a movie with
black kids they were fat babies kids
babies kids
yeah yeah yeah yeah God damn it what's
baby husbands oh my God before your time
bro she's Indian 100 I think she
actually might be half yeah
I think that might have been the first
black cartoon I see
um all right another topic all right you
want to talk about UFC yes wait but one
second before we leave this thing what
you're gonna say are white people really
upset at what that there's a black
mermaid
well actually yes go go go like on
YouTube apparently the dislikes like
they took off dislikes but if you have
different plugins you can see them the
dislikes are like massive yeah yeah on
this video there's probably comments of
people being like Oh that's [ __ ] up
here's the problem
there were two uh virtuous when they did
this originally like like we're gonna
change everything and make sure it's a
black one and it's going to be a female
transgender James Bond and it seemed
like they wanted too much Hollywood
wanted too many pats on the back I think
that if they just randomly did this
every once in a while it wouldn't be
that big a deal but the fact that they
do it and they're like look what we've
done yeah we're changing the World by
making mermaids black that gets a little
exhausting yeah crazy yeah right white
people want to claim these Ginger
mutants yes yeah I'd never claim them
before but now you guys oh redhead is on
the yeah yeah that's interesting yeah
that's a great good yeah how does the
redheaded Community feel about this they
should be upset they should they just
make her black but with red hair oh wait
they didn't give her no her hair was red
is it red yeah I think so I'm pretty
sure I thought she had some
right here dude yeah
right here brother yeah what you were
saying though there was a Cinderella I
think that came out like 20 25 years ago
with Brandy yeah and then the Godmother
was Whitney Houston nobody cared
actually because they didn't nobody was
outraged but they didn't make it it was
big but they didn't make it like they
didn't care because Brandy and Whitney
were incredibly popular and famous yeah
so it wasn't like Hey we're doing with
this with a random person of color so
that we can show that anybody can do
anything well yeah but the prince was a
Filipino guy yeah the Queen the prince's
mom was a black guy the King was a white
guy like it was colorblind casting
without making it a thing yeah it just
happened to be that way it seems like
weird when you watch a play that's what
it's like like if you go to Broadway and
you watch a play they'll just cast
anybody in whatever role yeah so I'm
like and I don't
really have any issue when I'm watching
the play Broadway's pretty liberal yeah
but you accept it you go there and
you're like yeah it's fine no big deal
but I think you're also suspending more
disbelief in a in a play because you
know this is fake and it's front of you
whereas when you watch a movie or a TV
show you're like no this is something
real then I'm just getting a little yeah
I'm eavesdropping I also think to your
point it was such a it's almost like
advertising copy to say hey look how
Progressive we are we are going to do
this if the Disney CEO didn't say half
of our characters are going to be
minorities I don't I think we just
watched in Kanto and be like this is lit
watch cocoa and been like this is lit
and we wouldn't have thought like oh
they're meeting their quota here's
another movie especially with this like
the director is Rob Marshall who's who's
like comes from musicals and he did
Chicago nine
um into the woods Mary Poppins like a
lot of white people he's cast like he
was just like who's the best at the time
the cat this was like in 2019 they cast
this film like I don't know she's
probably the best for that and they were
searching for a long time yeah yeah yeah
I guess I don't know but yeah apparently
people are mad about it they all like
the conservative new news pundits and
[ __ ] or yeah saying it's like an issue
white Erasure is like the big thing
that's so funny because I normally again
I was saying this on another interview
we had Republicans are usually really
good at like marketing but this is just
such like a woke term to use that people
are gonna crush it white Erasure it's
kind of like
um what are some of these other like
woke terms you hear not virtue signaling
but like there's oak caping or whatever
these terms are and you're like
exhausted by all of it white Erasure is
one of those terms they're like you'll
get the [ __ ] out of here with that woke
ass [ __ ] white Erasure it sounds like
some college dork thought of it you're
trying to erase the term altogether so
yes yeah I would love to erase the time
that's what they do right